before we start on the antisocial
Behavior stuff that I know you are Keen
to talk about I just don't want to get
your reaction to the Sting the
undercover expose by the anti-brexit
group led by donkeys Matt Hancock quasi
Quan saying among other MPS saying that
they would work for a fictional company
for ten thousand pounds a day it's
within the rules does that mean we
should care about the rules no I think
it's important that uh first of all that
we make sure that every MP operates in a
way which is transparent so when members
of parliament do do work which
complements the work that they do in the
House of Commons then it's absolutely
vital that we know who's paying them
what they earn and that's what the the
register is there for I think it's also
appropriate as well the Parliamentary
standards commissioner has the
opportunity to investigate and to look
at any activity that may uh cross the
line uh on this occasion I think it's
pretty clear that things that were
offered and things that were considered
were within the rules but inevitably all
of us will reflect on this and think the
the first duty of a member of parliament
is towards their constituents and
ultimately the really important thing is
is an MP delivering for their
constituents is a member of parliament
doing everything they can to put Public
Service First
is the other issue that they didn't seem
to do much due diligence on this company
did they given that it was non-existent
well again the the individual's
concerned we'll have to answer for
themselves uh it is the case that there
are members of parliament who do work
for
um a variety of organizations that
complements what they do so for example
Maria Caulfield Health Minister also
works as a nurse Dan Paul to previously
a health Minister works as a doctor so
it is possible to combine additional
activity with your responsibility
towards your constituents but each
individual MP must judge for themselves
is what they're doing something that
they can defend are they making sure
it's transparent and within the rules
but above all is it the case that
they're putting their constituents first
okay now you're announcing measures to
tackle anti-social Behavior today what's
the big idea well the most important
thing here is to recognize that
antisocial Behavior can ruin lives so
crime has been reduced neighborhood
crime has down as a result of the steps
that we've taken over the course of the
last 13 years but it's still the case
that in too many areas people's lives
are blighted by the type of activity
that in particular means that town
centers become no-go areas that parks
and public spaces become despoiled so
what we're saying is we want more
visible policing in those areas that we
know are hot spots for anti-social
Behavior we want to have faster justice
so that the jobs have been responsible
for doing damage in a particular area
repair damage more quickly but also we
need to nip this problem in the bud
right at the very beginning we need to
recognize that some of the the reasons
that fuel antisocial Behavior are
essentially to do with the way in which
uh young people are sometimes it's
neither support the structure that they
need and therefore we're looking in
particular at making sure that there are
other activities for young people and
I'm working with the education secretary
of course to look at truancy and
persistent absence as well faster
Justice yes um
these punishments could be turned around
in 48 hours there'd obviously be no
trial there not much chance to defend
yourself who actually
decides on the Justice what's the police
and crime commissioner because I just
wonder you know do we really trust the
police right now because it feels like
this is an elevated role for policing in
the papers today just to pick two
headlines strip Searchers of children as
young as eight shocking findings of my
report into please keep me awake said
the children's commissioner would my son
have been assaulted and held in custody
if he wasn't black Louise Casey review
of course found institutional misogyny
and racism in the police do we really
want to give them a bit more power here
well I think it's absolutely advisable
that we uphold the role of the police in
maintaining Law and Order that you're
absolutely the police you're absolutely
right to say that the Casey report was
shocking uh what it revealed about the
Metropolitan Police is unforgivable and
the commissioner Mark Rowley is taking
steps to deal with that but ultimately
we do have to make sure that our police
force can command confidence but it can
also be in a position to ensure that we
have order on our streets so
um we need to do two things we need to
make sure that where the police have
either been poorly LED or have been
operated waiting in a way that is
forfeited or risked public trust that
there is visible change but the
overwhelming majority of police officers
are people with a sense of vacation they
join the police because they want to
make a contribution to their Community
they want to uh deal with crime they
want to uphold and or delay public
environment and that's what we need to
do so if you are going to try and really
get this kind of fast Justice out yes
um do you commit to checking that it's
not disproportionately impacting people
from for example uh black backgrounds
yes and so one of the reasons why we're
piloting uh this approach in different
areas across the country is that we
believe it's absolutely right to Surge
police numbers in in these areas and to
have fast justice but the pilots are
intended to ensure that we can learn so
if for any reason there are ways of
operating that are not those which
command public confidence that we can
change and you are absolutely right as
well it's vitally important that the uh
the police operational way which is
entirely free of prejudice I should say
however that it is very often people
from uh black and minority ethnic
backgrounds who are disproportionately
the victims of crime so it is important
to recognize that if we want to have a
safe Society for every citizen in which
people whatever their background
whatever their circumstance can feel
safe that we need to take action and
anti-social behavior in particular is a
problem in uh in communities that have
been overlooked and undervalued in the
past it is part of leveling up to ensure
that people can feel that their High
streets are safe is the government
planning to ban laughing gas nitrous
oxide yes um
uh I think any of us who've had the
opportunity to walk through our parks in
our major cities
um will have seen these little canisters
these silver canisters which are
examples of people not only displaying
public spaces but also people taking a
drug which can have a psychological and
neurological effect and one that
contributes to anti-social Behavior
overall so this would be under the 1971
misuse of drugs act Class A Class B
Class C how did it work um I don't know
which class we would um attribute to it
but we would we want to make sure that
the uh the sailing use can be restricted
for its appropriate purpose we can't
have a situation we mustn't have a
situation where uh our Parks our public
spaces become drug taking Arenas um and
that is why we need to do Crackdown on
new manifestations of drug taking and
these laughing gas canisters are are an
increasing Scourge and one that's been
reported to me as a constituency MP and
the advisory Council on the misuse of
drugs recommended against making illegal
and they said the current evidence
suggests that Health and Social harms of
nitrous oxide are not commensurate very
nice weather with control under the
misuse of drugs act in 1971. I mean
you've done drugs yourself you've
admitted to taking cocaine on
certifications are you really going to
give people a quick criminal record for
taking laughing gas well we want to make
sure that we deal with the scourge and
uh it is the case that uh we need to be
clear that there are types of activity
particularly types of activity that
cause distress to others in public which
are unacceptable and of course it's
absolutely right that we uphold the law
in this case yes the advisory committee
have offered their advice but ultimately
it's ministers who are responsible and
we believe collectively that it is
absolutely vital that um we deal with
this Scourge and in the same way one of
the things that we're also doing is
making sure that there can be extended
drug testing of people who are
responsible for criminal and anti-social
activity we need to deal with it do you
not think there is a bit of an issue
where people may look at politicians
who've taken drugs themselves and
thinking hang on it's a bit hypocritical
no I think it's because I've learned
okay what have you learned that it's a
mistake worse than a mistake uh to uh
regard drug taking is somehow acceptable
okay
um now kirst armor said a labor got
government wouldn't treat cannabis as a
low-level crime he said as a family in
my constituency where every night
cannabis Creeps in from the street
outside into their children's bedroom
it's not low level it's ruining their
lives do you think that cannabis use
it's a low-level crime no I don't
believe it's a low-level crime um I
think that it is absolutely right that
people uh uh see the law upheld and the
experience of so many uh uh not just
with neighbors who behaving in an
anti-social way but in our high streets
and in our public parks is that they see
the law being floated and that's not
acceptable we do need to make sure that
um in public spaces order is maintained
and it's just not
to use the word they used earlier
commensurate with people feeling a
degree of pride in their Community to
see it being used as a uh you know a uh
free-for-all when it comes to Breaking
the Law and now tomorrow just to move on
to other topics MP is going to be voting
on the illegal migration Bill and people
who arrive in the UK and small boats
being deported including to countries
like Rwanda and now some rebels in the
conservative party are backing an
amendment that would ban British judges
from using legal precedent from the
European courts of Human Rights is that
realistic is it something the government
will consider well the most important
thing to do is to make sure that we pass
this legislation we've got to stop the
votes um and the conservative party
recognizes that the only way in which
you can have confidence in accepting new
people into this country as we have so
generously with the homes for Ukraine
scheme with Afghans with British
Nationals from Hong Kong is to control
our borders and I know that the
immigration Minister Robert Generac has
been working incredibly hard to make
sure that this legislation Works has
been talking to MPS who may be in a
position to ensure that every aspect of
this bill Works in my experience as a
minister it's always a good idea to talk
to Pat Adventures to make sure that your
legislation can achieve everything that
you hope it might how do you feel
personally I mean ask this question to
Oliver down as well how do you feel
personally about the idea of children
many from
very difficult
um backgrounds may have legitimate
Asylum claims being sent to Rwanda
um I think it's absolutely right that we
uphold the law one of the things that
we're doing alongside making sure that
we stop the boat is also establishing
safe and legal routes for assignments
it's more safe and legal routes should
be created then because as you and I
know it's not that easy to find a safe
and legal route from most countries in
the world well it's the Home Secretary
and the Prime Minister have made clear
that we want to establish those routes
so that we can take a number of people
should there be more than well
Parliament will decide uh how many
people we can take for you well my view
is that we should I I was um involved in
establishing creating and maintaining
the homes for Ukraine scheme I think we
should uh show compassion to people who
are fleeing persecution but we also need
to be clear about two things there is a
limit no country can have uh an infinite
number of new people around driving but
it's also the case that we need to
demonstrate that we have effective
control of our borders the people who
are exploiting the
um situation at the moment are criminal
organizations trading in human misery
um and we need to make it clear that
their business model will be broken
education secretary so I'm quite
interested to get your view on the
recent scrutiny of ofsted in the wake of
the you know very sad death of the head
teacher Ruth Perry
are offsped inspections placing too much
stress on teachers uh well the first
thing is uh obviously when you're
talking about circumstances where uh a
clearly public spirited talented
um you know passionately committed
person has taken their life you have to
have respect for
uh uh her example and her family so it's
important not to I think
um uh you know be too political
um when we're reflecting on uh her
passing uh I do think however that
ofsted plays an absolutely vital role in
providing information about how schools
are performing well which we can learn
from and which goals are not performing
well and therefore need help and
intervention I think there's some people
who said that the four four you get four
grades right and that's too much of a
blunt instrument it should be more
nuanced than that well I I I think that
those grades are important but there is
one issue which I do think we need to
reflect on and look at which is that if
a school is found to have failed its uh
its safeguarding criteria
then that is what is called a limiting
judgment and if a school is found
inadequate in that area that means it's
an adequate overall even if it has
strong teaching and learning and its
other areas are good as well so what is
safeguarding just explain what
safeguarding is the uh the set of rules
that govern the the well-being of
children within the school the health
and safety of the protection and so on I
do think we need to look at the uh the
way in which a limiting judgment as it's
called a technical term means that uh a
failure in one area means failure
everywhere else but
that is not a a criticism of ofsted
ofsted do a great job the Chief
Inspector Amanda Spielman is someone
absolutely committed to supporting
teachers to do better one of my worries
is that some of the people who are
attacking ofsted
um object to transparency are anti-high
standards and what we need to do is to
recognize that education has improved in
the last 13 years and the role of ofsted
under successive Chief inspectors has
been absolutely Central to that now
Westminster has been
gripped by Boris Johnson this week he
was giving evidence to the Privileges
committee about whether he deliberately
and or recklessly misled Parliament yes
partygate now back in 2016 I will never
forget the moment when you pull the plug
on supporting Boris Johnson's leadership
campaign yes and effectively torpedoed
his campaign by launching your own and I
just want to play what you said at the
time so this is back in 2016.
I so wanted that plan to work I worked
night and day for it
but I came to realize this week that for
all boris's formidable talents
he was not the right person for that
task
when you listen to Boris Johnson this
week did you think that you were right
all along no um I served as a member of
boris's cabinet during the time that he
was prime minister I think that uh as
prime minister he did a a very good job
for this country
um I think that uh the way in which he
managed to ensure that we left the
European Union and that the turmoil over
brexit at last came to a conclusion the
way in which he handled kovid and uh
oversaw the vaccine rollout the fastest
and most effective in Europe and also
the courage that he showed in standing
up to Russian aggression in Ukraine all
of that shows that uh as prime minister
uh he was someone who was operating in a
patriotic and public spirited way and so
um I will continue to feel affection and
respect for Boris Johnson as prime
minister I asked Greg hands pot chairman
this week if Boris Johnson was a man of
integrity
he didn't say he was he just said that
he was a great campaigning asset do you
think he was a man of integrity or is it
Integrity I think the Boris is someone
who puts the country first yes so you
think he's a man of integrity yes now
there's this one last thing that I want
to ask you about Matt Hancock's
whatsapps oh yes because a few of the
exchanges that appeared in the Daily
Telegraph between you and Matt Hancock
were to be completely I'm not actually
sure what adjective I should use to
describe them but we can just have a
quick look at some of the exchanges
between you and the health secretary
this is a YouTuber Hancock there lots of
emojis lots of affections why why do you
love Matt Hancock so much then
um because he was doing something I
think on that particular day that I
admired he was throwing himself into the
battle against covid um of course it's
the case that there are all sorts of
critiques of how we as a government
handled covert and we need to reflect on
those but I still believe that
notwithstanding other events that Matt
was someone who in that role was working
incredibly hard to uh to deal with the
virus and its effects and I think that
um were you taking the Mickey out of him
slightly I just wonder no not on that
this is all very serious right uh it was
uh an expression of earnest admiration
at a time when he was working incredibly
hard you are right that sometimes uh
when you're sending a WhatsApp people
may not recognize that you're saying it
with a twinkle in your eye but on this
occasion I was admire of what Matt did
okay and I think the key thing is you
know uh in politics uh we can often have
uh individuals who attract uh criticism
and oblique but
uh when people were working as Matt was
so hard to try to do the right thing
then we're all part of a team that
offers support this is my favorite what
are we trying to achieve in this meeting
letting people Express their concerns in
a therapeutic environment before you and
I decide the policy quite a lot of
meetings like that
I think you could probably say that that
was uh that was written with a twinkle
in my eye and uh my tongue in my cheek
from time to time on WhatsApp I suspect
even at the sky Newsroom uh though it
will be the case that people send
messages which are intended to provoke a
rise file rather than necessarily
provoke action okay thank you very much
indeed thank you